we're talking about
color it's our color hour monochromatic
looks
on trend and our next guest is going to
take her love of color to the next
level it's a monochromatic lifestyle she
recently went viral for loving pink so
much she
married it say what now she
yeah she married it it's her favorite
color and she's dated it for over 40
years and she's here to have a pink
party with us i love her spirit please
welcome kitten k syrah
well look at you
oh my gosh you look phenomenal for
starters
thank you so much i just love you too
you're hilarious oh thank you well we're
tickled pink that you're here
take me back to the beginning kitten
where and how what is the origin story
of this love affair with pink
okay so it was my 20th birthday i had on
pink from head to toe
it just felt right like i know this
sounds crazy but i had a spiritual
awakening that day i just knew from then
on it would be nothing but pink i went
home i gave everything to my four older
sisters
and from then on i've been in the pink
every day for 40 years i don't do any
other other look i do several a million
shades of pink mind you you know my life
is sort of my art as you can see like
i'm also a recording artist i'm working
on a new documentary called pinkist
because i'm the pinkest person in the
world and
so curious about my life so i thought
you know what i should do a documentary
that's what i'm actually doing right now
i love it i love your spirit yeah i want
to know um about the wedding
when you married pink who asked who i
need to know did
did pink get down on one knee and ask
you oh and there's the wedding ring it's
pink too
this is fat okay so what made you really
take this step kitty
why
okay so a kid on a skateboard believe it
or not randomly said to me when i was
walking down the west hollywood in an
illustrious pink outfit
he said
wow you love pink you and i said yeah i
love it so much you know and he's like
you love it so much why don't you marry
it and he was being sarcastic but i
thought it was hilarious and i thought
you know what this kid is on to
something and so for two years i mulled
around in my head about like how can i
make this work and make it fun and just
over the top and do it in vegas yeah and
kate harry was at my bachelorette party
like it was
off the charts we had so much fun
yeah um my best friend is friends with
her manager so we kind of hung out i got
pictures with katie back at her party at
wally's but yeah so i just thought
everything pink all the guests came in
pink and i said pinky promised that you
guys will wear pink and everybody did we
got
presley's pink cadillac and a little
white wedding chapel so it was
it was so much fun you guys and you know
i take i take life with the grain of
pink salt yeah i don't like take it
seriously
i thought what the heck i'm living my
life my way and i'm living it large life
is short so make it sweet sweet as
cotton candy
[Applause]
thank you kittens so much in your honor
look what we got
thank you so much kitten quesara because
you really helped push the idea of this
color hour into just the sweetest pink
and i'm so grateful thank you kitten k
syrah
[Music]